en el vídeo donde estudiamos los
orbitales con hibridación sp3 nos
metimos en muchos detalles sobre sobre
cómo se vería la molécula del metano así
que como como parte del repaso digamos
vamos a ver cómo era su figura de
tetraedro entonces teníamos un átomo de
carbono que estaba digamos en el centro
del tetraedro y que estaba unido a dos
hidrógenos digamos que se encontraban en
el mismo plano donde se encontraba este
este átomo de verdad podríamos pensar
que están en la misma hoja de papel pero
teníamos uno que salía un poco más allá
que se salía por digamos por enfrente de
nuestra hoja de papel o que teníamos ese
hidrógeno y además teníamos un hidrógeno
que estaba digamos por detrás de nuestra
hoja de papel entonces uno podría pensar
como que este es una figura digamos de
tetraedro verdad más o menos uno podría
verlo de esta forma
y esto nos habla de una especie de
tetraedro de una especie de tetraedro
ahí lo tienen de hecho sí sí por ejemplo
si lo tratar de dibujar a lo mejor un
poco rotado pues en realidad corresponde
a esta figura verdad a esta figura que
es nuestro tetraedro digamos puede ser
que nuestra primera cara que esté
formada por estos tres hidrógenos pues
corresponda a lo mejor a esta cara puede
ser que la otra cara a la que
corresponde a estos tres hidrógenos
corresponde a lo mejor a esta otra que a
lo mejor la que corresponde a estos tres
hidrógenos podría ser esta que está aquí
abajo verdad ésta que estoy rellenando
con puntitos y la restante pues sería la
de atrás verdad entonces esa es nuestra
figura de tetraedro del metano verdad
entonces está justamente de aquí es el
metano verdad de esta molécula
ahora qué pasaría si quisiéramos pintar
la molécula del etano entonces vamos a
pintar la molécula del etano y nosotros
sabemos que el etano tiene dos átomos de
carbono déjenme hacerlo un poco más
abajo tenemos dos átomos de carbono y en
cada uno de ellos tenemos unidos tres
hidrógenos tres hidrógenos ahí está
nuestra molécula del etano muy bien
entonces vamos a tratar de dibujar bueno
lo que sabemos es que cada uno de estos
carbonos tiene una hibridación sp3 pero
ya en conjunto cómo se vería vamos a
dibujarlo un poquito con perspectiva
digamos que este carbono de aquí es este
que estoy digamos pintando como más al
frente digamos vamos vamos a hacerlo un
poco más abajo vamos a pintarlo digamos
como que está al frente y está unido a
este otro átomo de carbono digamos que
está más atrás
y ahí tenemos nuestros dos átomos de
carbono dibujados con cierta perspectiva
entonces si por ejemplo quisiéramos
pintar este hidrógeno aunque y entonces
sabemos que debe que que este carbono
digamos forma como una especie de triple
verdad entonces a lo mejor tendríamos
algo así tendríamos unido a este
hidrógeno si por ejemplo este hidrógeno
de aquí lo ponemos con este color morado
a lo mejor este está un poco más salido
ok más o menos un poco más salido hacia
afuera y el otro el restante vamos a
ponerlo digamos con azul vamos a ponerlo
con este azul ok si ponemos este
hidrógeno a lo mejor se encuentra por
debajo muy bien entonces ahí tenemos más
o menos nuestra estructura de como de
tripié o de trípode de este de este
carbono verdad tenemos estos tres que
corresponden a la base del tripié y
digamos esta barrita que sale del centro
verdad ahora
el otro carbono también tiene esa misma
estructura entonces por ejemplo si
nosotros ponemos este hidrógeno este
hidrógeno a lo mejor corresponde a un
hidrógeno que que está saliendo digamos
algo así ok
más o menos y digamos que ahora este
hidrógeno de acá arriba este que tenemos
aquí corresponde por ejemplo algo que
está por acá y entonces aquí tenemos
nuestro otro hidrógeno y finalmente lo
dejamos con amarillo ok lo pintamos como
por aquí muy bien entonces aquí tenemos
una representación un poco más digamos
geométrica de cómo es la molécula del
etano ok entonces esto ya está dibujado
con cierta perspectiva y a esta a ésta
se le conoce como modelo modelo de
barras y esferas justamente porque como
verlo de esferas y barras justamente
porque nuestras bolitas o nuestros
átomos son esferas
los enlaces corresponden a las barras
y una forma más fácil en la que pude
haber dibujado esto es lo que se conoce
como la proyección de caballete verdad
entonces esto más o menos lo dibujar ya
digamos aquí tenemos nuestros átomos de
carbono y más o menos estos de acá
arriba pues corresponderían algo así
verdad algo así y este pues está más o
menos aquí abajo ok entonces esta misma
representación es lo que se conoce como
la proyección de caballete verdad
proyección de caballete y yo creo que
alguna vez has visto justamente un
caballete verdad busca una imagen y más
o menos se ve de esta forma entonces
esta es la proyección de caballete o la
forma de representarlo con la proyección
de caballete para el etanol ahora bien
si te pones a pensarlo esté realmente
como la forma más perezosa de hacerlo
hasta cierto punto verdad no estamos
dibujando todos los círculos y todo
bueno todo está configuración extraña
verdad simplemente nos estamos fijando
un poco
digamos en los ángulos cómo están
distribuidos los ángulos de entre los
carbonos y los hidrógenos qué es lo que
nos da nuestra configuración de
tetraedro pero en cualquier caso lo que
estamos tratando de visualizar de esta
molécula es la forma o más bien todas
las formas infinitas en las que puede
estar esto configurado y todo esto viene
justamente porque este de aquí este este
enlace de aquí es un enlace sigma verdad
este es un enlace sigma y nosotros
aprendimos en el vídeo de de hibridación
sp3 verdad que los enlaces sigma y en
los en los enlaces para este justamente
es un enlace sigma que nosotros
aprendimos que podemos rotar digamos
alrededor de los enlaces verdad así que
uno de estos carbonos por ejemplo
podríamos rotarlo verdad alrededor de
este eje para tener otra estructura ok
si por ejemplo tuviéramos un enlace
doble este este sería un enlace pi
y tendrían que rotar juntos así que
tendríamos por ejemplo
por ejemplo podríamos tener esta otra
configuración digamos tenemos
y tenemos nuestro carbono verdad vamos a
hacer justo en nuestro modelo de barras
y esferas de verdad y digamos que estos
estos hidrógenos perdón se quedan de la
misma forma que entonces tenemos aquí
nuestro hidrógeno amarillo nuestro
hidrógeno rosa ok y tenemos nuestro
hidrógeno morado ok esto se quedan igual
pero ahora vamos a hacer que estos
rotten digamos digamos por ejemplo que
este azul ahora se encuentra acá arriba
que ya entonces lo que hicimos fue rotar
este este este átomo de hidrógeno azul
lo rotamos hasta acá pero si rotamos el
átomo de hidrógeno en realidad todos
están rotando parejo entonces por
ejemplo este hidrógeno verde este
hidrógeno verde pasaría más o menos como
por aquí entonces podríamos ponerlo
digamos aquí verdad mientras que el otro
este de átomo de hidrógeno morado rota
también y entonces lo podríamos poner de
esta forma entonces estas dos son dos
estas dos son configuraciones distintas
que podemos tener para esta misma
molécula pero habría que preguntarnos
cuál es la verdadera diferencia aquí
tenemos los mismos átomos los mismos
enlaces cuál es la verdadera diferencia
bueno lo que pasa es que el el hidrógeno
podríamos imaginar que este hidrógeno de
acá por ejemplo y déjenme ver
espero que el dibujo les les ayude un
poco pero podríamos pensar por ejemplo
que este hidrógeno de aquí está
justamente adelante de este hidrógeno
verdad si si nosotros lo viéramos
digamos desde esta perspectiva si vemos
digamos en este en esta dirección
podríamos pensar que este hidrógeno está
justo adelante de este verdad o
podríamos pensar que este blanco está
delante de este verde verdad y lo mismo
podríamos pensar que éste está delante
de éste entonces si nosotros lo viéramos
justo desde este lado se verían como
como encimados verdad entonces realmente
está esto es lo que conoceríamos como
una configuración eclipsada o más bien
como una conformación vamos a ponerle
conformación
con formación eclipsada y justamente la
idea de eclipsada nos recuerda como los
eclipses que nosotros a veces observamos
como el eclipse de la luna o el eclipse
solar en donde hay un cuerpo que se
interpone entre entre otros dos por
ejemplo si nosotros estamos aquí y
queremos ver este hidrógeno de acá pues
hay uno que esté interponiéndose y no
nos deja ver la verdad entonces esta es
la conformación eclipsada ahora bien en
el otro caso si nosotros observamos
nuevamente desde este lado y nosotros
queremos observar este hidrógeno azul
pues podríamos verlo justo porque está
en medio de estos otros dos entonces a
esta conformación se le conoce como
conformación alterna alternada
es la conformación alternada y
justamente para poder distinguir muy
bien de cual estamos hablando podríamos
utilizar algo que se llaman las
proyecciones de de newman aunque
entonces vamos a hablar un poquito de lo
que es una proyección de newman y
simplemente es una forma de representar
estas estas moléculas ok
entonces una representa una proyección
de newman por ejemplo podríamos pensar
que este carbono el primero es un punto
vamos a pensar que este primer carbono
es un punto muy bien va a ser el carbono
de enfrente y ahora vamos a pintar los
tres hidrógenos que están unidos a este
carbono ok entonces tenemos nuestro
primer hidrógeno tenemos nuestro segundo
hidrógeno y vamos a pintar el tercer
hidrógeno muy bien entonces ahora vamos
a pensar que el segundo carbono es una
bola un poco más grande muy bien más o
menos entonces si si te pones a pensarlo
es justamente si estuviéramos viendo
esta molécula justo donde está esta
flecha muy bien y en esa dirección
entonces donde se vería esta este átomo
de hidrógeno azul pues dijimos que se
vería justo en medio de estos dos verdad
entonces justo lo pintamos aquí
el átomo verde de hidrógeno se vería
entre estos dos hidrógenos entonces lo
pintamos aquí y este átomo morado lo
podemos poner justamente aquí entonces
esta es la proyección de newman de una
conformación alternada verdad vamos a
ponerlo esta es la conformación alter
alternada muy bien ahora bien qué
pasaría si quisiéramos pintar la
proyección de newman pero de la
conformación eclipsada digamos entonces
pintamos nuevamente nuestro átomo
nuestro átomo de carbono del frente y
tenemos nuestros tres átomos de
hidrógeno
tenemos el amarillo tenemos el rosa y
tenemos el morado tenemos el morado
nuevamente vamos a pintar nuestro
segundo átomo de carbono
ok digamos como una esfera que está
justamente detrás de este primero
ok y el detalle aquí es que si yo
observar a través digamos el amarillo el
amarillo me tapa al ver de verdad
entonces realmente yo lo tendría que
poner como algo aquí pero esto lo haría
muy encimado y muy difícil de entender
entonces lo que lo que vamos a convenir
es vamos a ponerlo aquí muy cerquita muy
bien vamos a ponerlo muy cerquita que
pasaría por ejemplo con este morado que
se encuentra detrás del rosa pues éste
justamente lo pintamos muy cerquita de
éste rosa verdad y finalmente pues el
azul lo pintamos de la misma manera
verdad pintamos el azul de la misma
manera y esta sería la proyección de
newman para la conformación y clic
eclipsada ok esta es la proyección de
newman para la conformación eclipsa de
entonces como puedes darte cuenta las
proyecciones de newman nos sirven mucho
para entender cuál es digamos la
justamente la configuración a la o la
geometría de estas moléculas
y justamente en este caso puedes notar
que se están eclipsando digamos los dos
hidrógenos o hidrógenos que se
encuentran detrás de otros ok entonces
esto esto además nos ayuda a ver
muchísimas otras cosas en particular
podríamos pensar en la noción de
justamente que comentábamos del ángulo
entre dos hidrógenos distintos entonces
si yo por ejemplo quisiera medir cuál es
este ángulo este ángulo entre estos dos
dos hidrógenos bueno a este ángulo se le
conoce como ángulo yedro aunque el
ángulo
yedro entonces entre estos dos por
ejemplo en este caso habría 60 grados y
entre estos dos por ejemplo el amarillo
y el verde habría un ángulo de cero
grados entonces realmente el ángulo de
yedro nos está diciendo que tanto se
parece a la versión alternada
o que tanto se parece a la versión
eclipsada verdad si tiene un ángulo más
o menos de 60 grados pues estamos
pensando en una proyección o más bien
que representa una
con formación alternada si es un ángulo
de cero grados
entonces representa una conformación
eclipsada muy bien entonces ahora
todavía sigue la pregunta de por qué
esto es interesante o por qué nos sirve
y en realidad esto nos sirve porque
todos estos hidrógenos tienen nubes de
electrones alrededor de ellos y todos
estos enlaces tienen digamos también en
nubes de electrones alrededor de ellos y
es y las nubes de electrones todas son
negativas y quieren alejarse lo más
posible las zonas de las otras verdades
así que en estos dos casos ahorita se
encuentran en una situación estable
porque tienen todos sus enlaces de forma
que tienen estructuras estables y
agradables verdad todo mundo se siente
muy bien teniendo todos sus orbitales
completos y todo eso que ya hemos visto
así que estas nubes de electrones
quieren alejarse la zona de las otras
verdad así que en esta situación por
ejemplo en la conformación eclipsada
estos estos hidrógenos que se encuentran
cerca o más bien estos hidrógenos se
encuentran mucho más cerca
los unos de los otros verdad así que van
a atender a repeler se hasta llegar a
una conformación alternada verdad así
que digamos por ejemplo el hidrógeno más
cercano de este pues podría ser alguno
de estos dos por ejemplo a lo mejor el
verde verdad entonces hay una hay una
distancia considerable en el caso en el
que estamos hablando en la conformación
alternada y en realidad lo que podríamos
garantizar es que en general la
conformación alternaba va a ser mucho
más estable porque va a tener una menor
energía potencial así que ya puedes
imaginar que si empiezas con una
conformación eclipsada entonces estos
hidrógenos van a empezar a roto más bien
estos dos carbonos van a rotar alrededor
de este enlace para tratar de repeler se
y llegar eventualmente a una
conformación alterna así que puedes
verlo como que en realidad tiene una
energía potencial mucho más alta y va a
tratar de de girar
digamos o va a tratar de llegar a
estabilizarse a una conformación
porque en este en esta conformación los
hidrógenos se encuentran mucho más lejos
los unos de los otros